Starting at the top
with the Chrome logo,
it's pretty clear that it's
a set of colors, set of lines,
set of gradients, and
some pretty regular shapes.
In fact, if you open it up in DevTools,
you'll see that this is in SVG,
making it a vector image.
Sam's cute kittens are a photo, which
means that is by default a raster image.
That is to say,
it's a grid of colored dots.
The Mexican flag is pretty complex,
but believe it or not,
this is an SVG,
making it a vector graphic.
This middle part here is
obviously the tough part.
And while it does look complex,
you can make it with an SVG.
If you don't believe me, check out
in DevTools this file's source.
And for this last gradient, it can
be defined as some geometric rules
governing how the color should change,
so this one is also a vector image.
So the final tally is that
the Chrome logo is a vector,
the kitten is a raster.
And then the Mexican flag,
repeat background,
and gradient backgrounds
are all vector images.